during celebrations today take a moment
to remember that the Christmas Day is
not joyous for all the remains of a New
Jersey Green Beret killed in Afghanistan
returned to American soil today and what
is called the dignified transfer the
family of the Fallen agreed to have the
media cover the event Lucas Tomlinson
reports on the Pentagon on this solemn
occasion the remains of sergeant first
class Michael gold will return to Dover
Air Force Base on Christmas morning
president Trump's national security
adviser Robert O'Brien an army general
mark Milley chairman the Joint Chiefs of
Staff were among those honoring him the
33 year old New Jersey native is the
20th American killed in combat in
Afghanistan this year the Green Beret
had deployed to Afghanistan three times
and received four Bronze Stars sergeant
first class Coble leaves behind a
partner Jen and a daughter Zoey the
Taliban claimed responsibility for
bombing his vehicle in northern
Afghanistan this comes as the us-led
peace talks with the Taliban have
resumed but the Defense Secretary says
the United States is never going to let
Afghanistan become a safe haven for
terrorists until we are confident that
that mission is complete we will retain
a presence to do that 13,000 US troops
remain in Afghanistan at the height of
US military involvement in 2010 over a
hundred thousand deployed there as part
of then President Obama's surge roughly
five hundred were killed that year fewer
troops could spend next Christmas in
Afghanistan as the Pentagon weighs a
decision to pull nearly 4,000 troops out
and even more from other hotspots I'm
looking at CENTCOM I'm looking at
AFRICOM I'm looking at South comm I'm
looking at you comm all these places rec
and free up troops where I could either
bring them home to allow them to rest
and refit and retrain or and then
reallocate them to the indo-pacific to
compete with the Chinese with only 7,000
US troops deployed to Africa defense
officials say there's not many troops to
cut earlier this month the head of US
forces in Africa briefed espera in the
Pentagon secure conference room known as
the tank no final decisions were made
this year US forces have launched a
record number of drone strikes in
Somalia targeting an al-qaeda affiliate
and French forces have taken the lead in
West Africa their former colonies Mike
Lucas Tomlinson live at the Pentagon
Lucas many thanks